yeah welcome to this video playing black
against and international math I need to
check this I'll leave her hat or
something from Egypt how to pronounce
but basically this text here are four
hot yeah probably mispronouncing this
terribly em okay a coke on that you
played the c2 line leading to
interesting play okay it's quite similar
to Palm off but the deep one is not not
moved okay I took b6 and how do I
continue g6g six is this sir fine I hope
so I hope that there's down no one
direct reputations or anything this sir
now looks like relatively normal pan off
similar to what I recommended in my
video serious far as you see the opening
compass in German language of course
should I take now yeah probably first
castle yeah i'm i recommended this line
as an interesting way to unbalance the
game for black um can I take and play
you six now keep it simple I hope this
is working b6 what does he reply on e6
d6 and maybe option to 35 mm hmm also I
think Bishop takes c3 was suppose bad am
this is
this is really not down to be
recommended e6e 66 Bishop Bishop er yep
can play Bishop g5 it's a bitter but
annoying the smooth
okay let's play prophylactic move it's
not better anyway covering the pond
so how to continue Bishop this Bishop is
nice and in terms of being a Bishop
Bishop bishops are okay but it's not
doing much yeah maybe I need to just
just exchange this piece to get some
some room for the pieces okay he's may
be intending to play D 6m the ideas some
maybe Luke c5 putting more pressure on
on the d5 point
hmm no I'm not not sure what white
should do now it sir it looks nice for
white I'm not not saying at all that he
that is get some problem or anything but
I don't don't see an easy way to to
improve the position rocky 3 i'm not
sure everyone's to play up to e3
intensifying play on e7 not sure I mean
by now I would really take on c3 and
take d 5 fee does some some nothing move
ok this one question is how do I react
to I just take yeah then maybe em he'll
take on bucetinha this is this is
unfortunate but do I have anything else
if I play Bishop c3 first and I know
this looks like complete nonsense nobody
threatening to take yeah probably i
don't have a big choice Queen between b7
is this really a problem I now know I've
got the got Queenie one right
and this one
so takes and look where I'm at five was
he six maybe see 60m he cannot go bishop
if I from protecting this and he cannot
take on b7 as well yeah this isn't so
one hundred percent easy because some of
my wicking 94 for example the idea of 94
s is very annoying let's get the Queen
back and maybe allow 95 lets in 94-95
centralizing pieces i'm also taking b3
of course maybe this one I really want
to get the Queen's off this would help a
lot Queenie to I've got rookie 6 and he
needs to take care about the night and
the Queen EK go Queen have one but this
is just just stupid so maybe he needs to
exchange queens now and then it's it's
very good for black Queenie to rookie
six so
I there's no technical trick there maybe
Queenie to rookie 6 screen everyone but
it's it's it's not looking good I can
just take be three at the end of the
slide I don't Akane a 94 I am 94 so then
I will still the Queen on everyone what
kind of i can go Queen to d2 may be
threatening rookie one or rookie too
young ok maybe needs to exchange queens
but this is an easy one 2595 987 rugby 6
and I just wouldn't be 3 + b2 yeah ok
this should be relative relatively easy
technically so on I've got the very good
knight on d5 and he's got those spawn
weaknesses and I need to if possible win
another pawn rook be one rupee to for
example
yes but he doesn't have any moves with
the night any substantial moves mp3 is
also hanging with check so
yeah it's not so easy to make with my
Dan bishop and in this case it's simply
nothing
check hmm check
yeah obviously I'm doesn't intend to
resign
yeah I'm not sure I think I'm around
here it looks it looks a bit bit shaky
for black well computer things are just
just okay yeah I was I was a bit worried
here okay this is just blundered the
game the problem was that in fact my
piece is very quickly I'm coordinated
here and he doesn't really have any any
big threats 94 to f6 would be nice but
it's simply covered and once you move
the night 94 I play 95 and control all
squares this Bishop is also on the
completely wrong diagonal if it would be
on c3 yeah let's say the pieces would be
swapped yeah bishop on c3 night on g3
then this would be something entirely
different with with those we can square
surround the king yeah interesting game
thanks for watching